have you guys ever seen displays that
are as unique as these ones for decades
modders have been almost the same the
same rectangle with the same basic
features but in the last few years we
are finally seeing some major changes in
Innovation and LG has created some
extremely unique monitors with some
super cool crazy designs and features
that can both improve your productivity
and fun now LG wanted to partner with us
and after we saw their new monitors and
how insanely interesting they are we
agreed since these stand out so much
from the other monitors that we have
tested and used this right here is LG's
smart Monitor and it is the future of
do-it-all monitors that are designed not
only for work but also for play and
anything else you want to do that is
because not only are you able to connect
your computer for example I have my Mac
connected here of course you can connect
a PC or anything else but you can also
connect your a gaming console as well as
any other smart boxes or anything really
that you have or it also has a ton of
built-in apps and streaming options
built right into it because it does have
its own processor and its own operating
system so that means that you don't even
need to have a computer connected to it
you can use the built-in Wi-Fi or the
Lan to do so many things like smart apps
and games applications all with just the
monitor now one of the things I like
most about it is it's Sleek design I
like that it uses a white shell instead
of your regular darker shells I think it
stands out it looks less like a normal
Monitor and what is super cool about it
is its stand it's called the Ergo stand
and instead of having a regular stand
that sits on your desk and takes up a
lot of room this thing has the column on
the back that actually mounts to your
desk and that saves you a lot of space
but it also gives you a lot of
flexibility for adjustment for example
you can go up you can go down you can
actually pull it out I know it's getting
cut off on video there you can pull it
in closer to your wall you can also
adjust the axis of the monitor so if you
want to spin it you can do that as well
it gives you a lot of flexibility
there's also channels so you can run
your cabling so you don't see that and
that's really cool and I know a lot of
people actually buy stands like this
separately after they buy the display
they spend a lot of money just to have
this capability but this thing actually
comes with it which is really sweet now
as far as connectivity not only do you
get regular HDMI which is what I'm using
right now connected to my MacBook but
you get a second one that supports Arc
and e-arc which is very important for
home theater uh TVs where you can have
signal going back to whatever you have
it connected to so you can have full
control that is really awesome now you
also have a lan Port which is cool if
you don't want to use the built-in Wi-Fi
and you also have USB in and USB type-c
as well that will allow you to connect
your computer to it with just one cable
and you can actually charge up a laptop
with 65 watt charging at the same time
with just one cable and you're not just
limited to those physical connections
you can also connect to it wirelessly
which is really cool now this thing is a
32 inch display so it's nice and large
you get a large screen real estate and
it is a 4K display and not is it only 4K
but it also has a DCI P3 color gamut
which is great for color accuracy both
for watching HDR videos and movies and
if you're going to be color correcting
video or HDR photos you kind of need
that to have the full color range
instead of just being limited to srgb
now you can easily swap from your
computer to a gaming console if you have
both of them hooked up and for gaming it
will actually support five milliseconds
refresh rates so it's not going to be
lagging or delaying you now of course it
does have speakers built into it so you
don't have to buy separate ones that's
great if you're watching videos and you
also get this remote that has a bunch of
different features you have shortcuts
for apps like Netflix Disney Prime video
you have your full controls you have a
little uh touch pad right here and this
just makes it really helpful to be able
to control it and as I mentioned you can
stream to it using Miracast or you can
use airplay 2 from your Mac your iPhone
your iPad so that makes it very flexible
now there are a ton of apps that this of
ports there are some that are
pre-downloaded and others that you can
download along with over 300 free LG
channels which means that you don't have
to pay for certain services to be able
to watch content on the TV now it also
connects to internet of things
accessories and different appliances as
well so it actually works kind of like a
Smart Hub so if you're looking for a 4K
display that is large and it not only
works a display but it can do everything
else at once including all those apps
this is a great all-in-one solution that
is priced really well takes up not a lot
of space on your desk and it's just
really cool to see monitors that are
doing something different and give you a
lot of value instead of just being a
monitor now this next one has so much
screen real estate that I actually can't
be sitting here and have it set up so
for those of you guys that need to
maximize your screen real estate check
out the LG ergo duel now it's always
tough to find a dual monitor setup that
works great together and doesn't take up
a ton of room and the Ergo dual comes
with two monitors that perfectly match
and a really great stand now early
stands out is that this setup is
perfectly designed and balanced first
you have the built-in arm stand that
allows you to swivel tilt and adjust the
height now this gives you maximum
control with free positioning and
movement to maximize your focus and
immersion to get the best productivity
and there are so many modes that you can
set this up in not just two monitors
side by side on their website they show
off being able to have both of them
vertically or one horizontal one
vertically tilting in different ways and
even having one stand with the two
monitors connected to two separate
computers so you can have two people
working on one desk without taking up a
ton of room
now these are 1440p monitors with srgb
color gamut and they have a wide variety
of ports including USB and USB type-c
where you can once again connect with
one cable and also charge your laptop
but what's really cool is that you can
actually daisy chain these together if
you use the right cables and both
monitors will connect and then connect
to your machine with just one cable
which is really sweet and that just
gives you a nice clean minimalist setup
while maximizing your screen real estate
and this is the LG dualup as you guys
could see it is very unique because it's
not the same shape and aspect ratio like
most monitors are it is very rare to
find a monitor with a 16 by 18 ratio Now
While most displays are going wider this
gives you a lot of vertical space which
is very helpful for many applications it
is basically the equivalent of having
two stacked 21.5 inch monitor years
without having to deal with extra bezels
cables all of that it takes up very
little horizontal room and this is great
for small spaces it also comes with an
excellent Ergo stand that attaches to
your desk with lots of adjustability to
get the right angle and put the monitor
where you want it and the stand is
actually upgraded from the last
generation to give you more
adjustability and customization so you
can just adjust to whatever works best
for you now this is great for Creative
content for example video editing where
you really benefit from having extra
vertical space to see more of your
timeline and video preview it also has
DCI P3 color gamut and an ambient light
sensor and you can use it as two
monitors when connecting with HDMI and
once again with USB type c and picture
by picture mode which is really cool you
have a variety of ports and once again
the USB type-c input can accept a video
signal and give you charging this time
up to 90 Watts and this display does
have speakers built in as well so if
you're looking for something that's
going to maximize your vertical space it
won't take up a lot of room on your desk
and can just be adjusted to however you
want it to be the distance from you a
lot of adjustability for height this
thing is an excellent choice and this
right here is the
libero monitor it has a design nothing
like what you have seen which is made to
fit your space and this monitor is a red
dot Award winner as you guys could see
as a stylish design that doesn't look
like a normal Monitor and it has a metal
stand built in with a fabric like
pattern on the back it is a 27 inch
1440p display that is very very
versatile it can be placed on your desk
like this or they actually include a
bunch of Hardware in the Box multiple
different arms so you can mount it
upside down you can literally hang it if
you would like to and it has Auto
reverse so your image shows up properly
now because of the design and the stand
it sits low to your desk it takes up
very little depth and the bezels are
super slim so it's nice and minimalistic
and if you guys see this thing on top
right here this is actually a webcam
that is fully detachable so when you
flip this thing upside down if you hang
it you could still attach it on the
other side as well now you also have a
privacy cover that you can use if you
want to keep it plugged in but of course
you could also just detach it which is
great it's a 1080p webcam with a
microphone built in and it's great for a
video conferencing now of course we have
speakers built in you guys see these
wave Max speakers and it has LG's Switch
app for various functions and to use a
split mode now on this other side you
have your ports and connectivity that
way no matter how you set it up you have
access to it even if it's flush against
the wall we have HDMI as well as USB
type c where you can charge your laptop
with up to 65 Watts as well as sending
the signal the build quality is really
nice and the stand as well as the
hangers are all metal just like the Ergo
stands they also use a lot of metal so
it's nice and stable so I just think it
is super cool that we have something
that's unique and LG is creating these
unique monitor solutions that are not
just your basic regular monitor so if
you're looking for something that looks
different and stylish it can be hung up
this monitor is a great choice so there
we have it we have four great LG
monitors that are set up for whatever
you need whether it's a different aspect
ratio or you want to have the most real
estate possible or a monitor or display
that does everything including smart
apps and different connectivity or
something that's very unique and very
different like this one LG has got you
covered so we're gonna have all the
links down in the description below you
guys can go and check it out let me know
which one you guys like the best or
which one you think is the most unique
and different go ahead and click that
Circle above to subscribe check out one
of those great videos are over there
this is the max and I'll see you in the
next one
foreign